who are you scared to fail in front of
the reason so many of you are not doing
what you want to do is you're scared to
fail in some you're scared that your
brother will judge you your wife your
girlfriend your husband and most scary
your mom or your dad you need to
eliminate that and/or own that fear and
put yourself in a position to succeed
because with all of this with all of
this we are now in the greatest era for
the first time ever with no [ __ ]
money with no goddamn connections this
can put you on the map if you're good
enough if you are good enough to be up
here to make bling-bling if you are good
enough nobody's stopping you not [ __ ]
Donald Trump not the [ __ ] Russians
nobody if you are a minority if you are
a female if you are a transgender if
you're a [ __ ] alien the market
doesn't give a [ __ ] if you make the best
[ __ ] you will win
do you know suck it was to be a nerd 20
years ago but now the market is
rewarding [ __ ] nerds
and now they're rock stars clap it up if
you're a [ __ ] nerd
the best part about that was so some
dude was clapping for him I said clap it
up and [ __ ] heard he was like sauce